so Liam Hemsworth has signed on to do
The Witcher he's going to be appearing
in series 4. but does this mean that
Stargate is back to square one because
it no longer has the lead actor it
wanted
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and
Movie Channel on my holidays
[Music]
okay so I did a video a couple of weeks
ago and I was telling you guys how this
Liam Hemsworth was having ongoing
discussions with MGM about um starring
in the new Stargate franchise but not
just starring he wanted to produce and
there was even conversations about maybe
show running I'll explain how that
happened in a second
but snooze broke yesterday that he is
actually now going to be starring in The
Witcher now Henry Cavill is back as
Superman and probably doesn't really
have time for it but also there are a
few rumors there as well which I'll
discuss in a second I am on my holidays
in the beautiful North Wales so with my
dog look there you go hello Harry Harry
Harry Harry Harry
um so apologize if this is any wind on
the video
so first of all let's just quickly talk
about Liam Hemsworth and where he uh
messed up with MGM
first of all he was approached around
six months ago to potentially star in
the new franchise this was back when MGM
still believed they were going to be
able to do what they wanted with
Stargate
Amazon continued those negotiations and
were continuing negotiations right up
until around two weeks ago this was when
they found out Liam's Hemsworth was
actually negotiating with Netflix
now apparently the actual announcement
was actually a surprise to MGM because
they didn't know anything had been
agreed they thought they were still
negotiating and then all of a sudden
we find out he's going to be The Witcher
to say the least on Friday I started to
get a few messages saying that the Liam
Hemsworth deal was going to go through
they didn't exactly know where he was
going at that point the sources I speak
to at least but they realized something
was going wrong
so does this mean star gets back to
square one
well the negotiations William Hemsworth
were being dragged out for so long
mainly because MGM don't have a chief
executive in charge of movies so they
couldn't push forward with any movie
idea they had and they don't have a
showrunner for the new Star great
franchise so they didn't really want to
push forwards with that that was why
Liam Hemsworth started pushing for the
show on a post as negotiations went on
he said yes I'd love to start I'd like
to produce
we don't have a showroom we don't have a
showroom okay well I well I don't I
could be a showrunner and get me a team
around me I'll do it but obviously then
those negotiations carried on because
Amazon were not overly keen on that idea
so he's now gone to The Witcher I know a
little bit about that deal that he's
signed with um Netflix so he will be
getting the producer role which is
something he wanted desperate of MGM for
the Stargate franchise he will also be
getting other projects through Netflix
this is kind of similar to the deal
um Henry Cavill had with Netflix when he
signed on to do The Witcher and that's
why Henry Cavill did things like Enola
Holmes and a couple of other projects
because Liam's Hemsworth like Henry
Cavill is sort of like pitching his
posts to Netflix this isn't just about
the one show it's about his overall
career
Stargate though it really does mean that
there's a little bit of a back to square
one situation going on
now the rumor is that they know who
their showrun is going to be but they
aren't able to sign up till around
Christmas time
they had an idea who the star of the
show is going to be and who they were
going to build around a lot of the show
around just like they built sg1 around
Richard Dean Anderson they were going to
build this new franchise at least
initially around Liam Hemsworth a name
that people know
now that's not going to happen so
Stargate and whoever's going to be the
new showrunner really does have to start
again because I have to find somebody
new to build the franchise around
and what does this news mean for The
Witcher a series I seriously adore
series 4 will be the last series of The
Witcher I almost guarantee Liam's
Hemsworth
if he does a Henry Cavill impression
which he's kind of got to and then
that's just going to be weird I think I
would be amazed if that worked
but hey let's see I don't think he's got
the look of Henry Cavill I don't think
he's got the build
um he's really gonna have to bulk up a
lot to fill that role but Henry Cavill
really did carry that show he was
amazing in it now there are some rumors
that one of the reasons why Henry Cavill
is moving away from The Witcher is
because that the producers want to take
the show in a slightly different
direction they keep messing with the
Canon of the story and this is a
character kendrickville really loves we
all know he's a massive geek and that
that was frustrating
I hear that's not necessarily true
um that these Necessities negotiations
changed right around the time Henry
Cavill got the all clear with Warner
Brothers and the new DC Universe DC
Studios that he was going to be coming
back a Superman full time there's going
to be another Man of Steel movie and
there's lots of other things going on
and he Henry Cavill apparently just
feels it's just the right time to step
away and that he cannot give the time
and effort into The Witcher that he
would want to so that is the main reason
why but the rumors about the whole thing
with breaking Cannon stuff
because Henry Cavill is a massive geek I
wouldn't dismiss them
but what does this really mean for
Stargate then are they back to square
one
no I don't think so
um the whole thing with MGM is that
they've not been in a massive rush to
get things up and running because they
don't have a showrunner because they
don't have an executive Enchanted movies
they do have a plan they were talking
nine months ago about being in a rush to
deliver this plan but it seems that
economic restrictions and a few other
things have uh meant that that's now a
bit Limited
um I think they're in no rush they want
to get the right people in place first
um really the movie the chief executive
in charge of the studio is the big one
they really do want to get the right
person in charge there
and that they really are taking the time
I think Liam Hemsworth would have been
great in Stargate I think he's just a
big enough name that it would have
attracted to attention but not too big
that it would have caused a problem so I
think that might have been the sort of
level of active that they're looking for
but there are plenty of actors out there
that once they've got a new showrunner
and that they can start actually getting
scripts and things done they will
attract the right sort of talent
so let's just hope that this doesn't
slow things down too much
now as you know I've been telling you
that we thoroughly expect an
announcement by Christmas about Stargate
could this slow that down
I've got to be honest with you possibly
I think they're gonna want all of the
pieces in place showrunner the lead
actor all of this sort of thing before
they make any big announcement on the
series
but I'm pretty confident I'll find out
before that happens so let's see and
let's just hope that this isn't going to
delay things too much but as long as
we're here by Christmas
the MGM have a new chief executive in
charge of movies
and that we get a couple of more
um sign-ins like that MGM have been
doing the last couple of weeks new
people getting on long-term contracts
and things people that could run this
show then I think
um we'll know it's coming even if the
official announcement gets pushed back a
little bit while they're looking for a
new act to delete it so let's just see
um I could also say that actually I have
had a few little more rumors about the
showrunner potentially and that the room
is basically either actually MGM might
be scrapping the idea of the person they
have
um already sort of like verbally agreed
with and because there is somebody
internally
that is potentially going to all they
believe could actually take the role on
um I don't know any more than that at
the moment so it's a little bit of a
vague rumor but it does seem like
MGM and Amazon are putting up
contingency plans for this sort of thing
so again it's that's kind of a bit of a
wait and see but even with that rumor
I'm being told it's still going to be
Christmas that they want to get somebody
um officially signed on so that's the
rumors that's all there's what's going
on that's Henry Cavill and Liam
Hemsworth dealt with we're still up in
the air with our the Stargate series but
I'd love to you guys get in the comments
and tell me exactly what you think I'm
starting to become frustrated by this
whole Saga but it does still feel like
we're inching towards getting a new
Stargate franchise it's just taking a
damn sight longer than it should but get
in the comments tell me what you think
also if you're new to the Channel please
like subscribe hit that Bell
notification
um I do lots of videos like this where
we can talk and I love to get into the
comments and have chats with you guys so
please do also if you like the content
please don't forget you can become a
fully pleasure site tracker and hit that
join button as always please stay safe
I'll see you next time
[Music]